spies have had German companies under
surveillance for years technological
data customer data company strategies
all this information is valuable to the
competition but also to foreign
espionage agencies hackers search for
weak points in computer systems no
country in the world is more spied upon
than Germany IT experts like hoga
makovski from the M privacy firm warned
that many companies underestimate the
danger services have departments devoted
specifically to industrial espionage and
they use various technologies they work
a lot with the internet and all
internet-based systems many companies
are networked and have internet presence
and have access to the Internet and
hackers gained access to the company
through these gateways but a state
agency spying on companies in its own
country is new Germany's federal
Intelligence Agency which is building a
new headquarters in Berlin is reported
to have helped an American secret agency
gather data one target of espionage is
Airbus which builds both civilian and
military aircraft Airbus released this
written statement on may 7 2015 we are
aware that as a large company in the
sector we are a target and subject of
espionage we have therefore asked the
German government for information and
are in dialogue with them we will now
file a criminal complaint against
persons unknown on suspicion of
industrial espionage
how far our secret intelligence agencies
allowed to go in the name of security do
they focus solely on the arms industry
or do they gather other data as well
many questions remain unanswered but not
everyone is critical of the surveillance
the US has a geopolitical interest in
where our German arms manufacturers do
business or in infrastructure Builders
like Siemens which does a tremendous
volume of business with China or when
things are sold to Iran sometimes
something is out of the ordinary
components that Iran is not supposed to
get in the context of its nuclear
program for example that is under
observation this is how Germany's
federal intelligence service the BND
sees itself the federal intelligence
agency is responsible for detecting
foreign espionage activity at an early
stage in order to limit or prevent
damage more and more German companies
are setting up their own protection
against unwanted snooping
the Berlin company M privacy offers
special software that goes beyond
firewalls and antivirus programs the
intelligence agencies have much more
massive means they can watch over
everything
they filter specific keywords they have
a much wider view they have the
technical means to listen in on all
communication not just Internet traffic
but also telephone fax and mobile phone
communications for Firefox Vecchia I
don't know often in the head of the M
privacy computer security firm thinks
the role of the BND is problematic
companies have to protect themselves
trust in state structures is damaged if
not totally destroyed by a revelation
that a country's domestic intelligence
service which ought to protect the
country's companies is spying on its own
industries for a foreign intelligence
service it's a massive breach of trust
who spies on whom and why intelligence
services operate in a grey zone and the
more globalized and networked the world
economy becomes the more data available
on the Internet the easier it is for
spies to snoop around
you